[Musique]
nous venons de présenter est adopté ce
jeudi matin au sénat un rapport sur la
place des femmes
en ruralité avec 70 recommandations
adoptées dans un certain nombre de
domaine c'était au sein de la délégation
aux droits des femmes parmi les constats
les recommandations et difficultés de
transmission entreprenariale difficultés
dans la transmission aussi
d'exploitations agricoles le constat
également que
mobilité sont encore plus prégnant quand
on est femme en milieu rural qui fait
que quatre déplacer sujets de santé
aussi avec des constats très alarmant
plus de gynécologues dont près de 13
départements difficulté ou encore
d'accéder à des offres de soins un suivi
spécifique en matière de santé donc
évidemment derrière des propositions
pour améliorer la mobilité ou améliorer
ces questions aussi de taxer au prêt
bancaire puisque le constat a été fait
que c'était plus difficile pour une
femme aux gros un homme
alors on a fait ensemble de propositions
qui ont tous été adoptés à cet honnet à
finir cette présentation de rapports par
ce point là parce qu' une des solutions
dans la santé pour la santé des femmes
en milieu rural c'est peut-être les
consultations gynécologiques avec eux
des moyens itinérant et des sages-femmes
et donc nous allons terminer par un un
message encore de soutien cette semaine
au combat des sages femmes pour une
juste valorisation de leur place se
donne deux sociétés
[Musique]